у військовій формі ЗСУ Сергій мокренюк
прийшов на особливе для нього місце на
Київський Майдан Незалежності Сергій
активіст та правозахисник у 2013-му
разом із тисячами мітингувальників
Євромайдану він почав боротьбу за зміни
в Україні
[оплески]
власне тут стояла наша наш табір стояв
то було перегороджено барикади тут було
неймовірна кількість людей втім історія
Сергія почалася зовсім не у Києві а у
рідному Криму
[оплески]
листопад 2013-го звідси Сергій починає
відлік подій яких не очікував Ні він ні
самі кримці каже він однак Росія завжди
готувалася до окупації півострова і тоді
в часи коли українці на протестах у
Києві та у Криму де був Сергій обирають
курс на євроінтеграцію російська
пропаганда переходить до дій
інформаційний спростір Він був
захоплений власне тими хто володіє
грошима на той момент це було Партія
регіонів мені дзвонить один журналістів
і кажу ой Слухай ти ж там мета саме на
Майдані був Ми якраз програму робимо То
може ти Приїдеш і розкажеш і от вони тут
розказують і така тема Крим чи можливо
повернення до Конституції 91-го року я
розумію що ця програма була це така була
підготовка Сергій разом з активістами
Андрієм ковальським Андрієм щекуном та
ісмаїлом ізмаїловим щоденно
організовували мирні акції у Феодосії та
Сімферополі куди приїздили тисячі
українців з усього півострова
серед псевдореферендумом на півострові
Сергія та інших активістів як розказує
чоловік почали переслідувати палити їх
автівки А на самого Сергія та його
жінкою дітей одного разу напали на
вулиці 9 березня Ми в Сімферополі
проводили акцію
формально вона була присвячена 200-річчю
Тараса Шевченка а реально ми збирали
всіх саме під лозун за за соборну
Україну за суверенітет і тому приїхала
туди досить багато людей десь близько
2,5 тисяч саме в цей день зранку росіяни
викрили андріяші куна і викрали Анатолія
каваського
в цей момент я мав розмову з
представниками між лісу
сказав що ми будемо блокувати дорогу для
того щоб вимагати щоб звільнились чи
конайковайського
проте представники міжліса просили цього
категорично не робити і власне Я
зрозумів якщо
ми вже не готові до таких простих дій як
як перекриття вулиці то Ну нема шансів
щось швидко або якісно зробити Я виїхав
з Криму 10 березня
14-го року на питання як сталося так що
Росія змогла окупувати півострів у 2014
році Сергій мокренюк сьогодні відповідає
так тоді Народ не був готовий боротися а
зрадників не було кому зупинити люди які
вчиняли державну зраду розраховувалися
годинами Це було ну окремі люди
проявляли досить активно свою позицію а
окремі навпаки повністю працювали на
росіян дехто був просто изначально
завербованим росіянами хто більше
вкладав ресурсів той власне там і
переміг тому я думаю що це більше
боротьба була між державами в таку і
довгу і довгу конструкцію ну росіяни
вклали більше ресурсів росіяни на той
момент виграли але це тактична перемога
не стратегічна
з моменту виїзду з півострова Сергій
документує злочини росіян у Криму працює
над розробкою санкційних законопроектів
проти РФ та тримає зв'язок з групами
кримських партизанів Ця робота не
припиняється досі каже Сергій навіть
після того як 24 лютого 2022 він вступив
до лавзсу ті люди які там кожен день
щось роблять для того щоб Росія не з'їла
Крим до кінця вони є присутні Вони
борються бо це боротьба різна різні
форми Але я точно можу стверджувати що
Росія ще не перетравила Крим Тобто вона
відкусити відкусила погористи погризла
жує але не перетравила сьогодні Сергій
тримає зв'язок із колишніми активістами
Кримського та Київського майдану чимало
з яких разом із ним нині в лавах
Збройних сил Усі вони налаштовані рішуче
звільняти українські землі кожен на
своєму бойовому напрямку Сергій мокринюк
певен його Крим вже цьогоріч повернуть
під контроль України бо держава
переосмислила підхід до його звільнення
я був впевнений що
дипломатичний шлях він є одним з
інструментів який можливий але Справа в
тому що на мою думку ми не
використовували його в повній мірі Ну
наприклад елементарне це те що в 14-му
році Крим був окупований але санкції
саме за Крим щодо росіян і інших були
застосовані тільки в 19-му році перемога
для Криму - це звільнення абсолютно всіх
територій України Ще багато років тому я
озвучив сценарій звільнення Криму І він
був дуже простий в один день вони просто
звідти втечуть
її ділиться із
нами показати свою малу батьківщину
дітям які в часи окупації Криму були ще
дуже малі і нічого не пам'ятають про
феодосію А ще нарешті побачитися з
батьками з якими протягом більш як кроку
немає жодного зв'язку